la toile du stade olympique a maintenant
20 ans et les signes ne manquent pas
elles arrivent en fin de vie on se
retrouve dans le fond dans les combles
de la toiture c'est à dire entre les
deux toiles entre la toile bleue convoi
de l'intérieur et la toile blanche qu'on
voit de l'extérieur du stade une des
choses qui frappe ici c'est le nombre de
rustines sur la toile c'est à dire ce
genre de pansements que l'on pose à
chaque endroit où on a découvert une
déchirure
seulement cette année 3256 nouvelles
déchirures dans la toile ont été trouvés
à ce jour le toit eu besoin de 11000 166
réparation des travaux de trois à quatre
cent mille dollars par année sont
nécessaires pour le garder sécuritaire
mais changer la toile n'est pas une
mince affaire
la régie des installations olympiques
vise maintenant 2024 plutôt que 2022
on veut passer beaucoup plus de temps à
analyser les impacts d'un concept sur la
structure sont nos stades
vous savez le stade olympique c'est un
objet structurale très complexe et ça
demande beaucoup d'efforts pour y
réfléchir on doit respecter les faits de
légèreté qui était souhaité par la toile
de jean dauger taiba donc on essaye de
revenir à ça j'ai énormément des voix
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait
deux firmes allemandes à l'origine d'une
cinquantaine de toi de stade dont celui
du bc place de vancouver réfléchissent
aux futurs concepts pour le stade
olympique
la herriot leur demande d'évaluer la
possibilité de pouvoir retirer une
partie du futur toit ce qu'elle appelle
un opercule en cas d'événement
exceptionnel comme la coupe du monde de
saut caire mais plus question de toit
rétractable comme le premier de 1987 qui
s'est usé prématurément la seule
prescription qu'on peut dire pour doper
recul il faut que ce soit suffisamment
grand pour couvrir un terrain de foot
nos spécialistes sont ceux qui vont se
pencher sérieusement sur cette solution
là pour voir si on peut la faire si
c'est techniquement faisable mais à quel
coût opel fanless de montréal ont manqué
d'amour robe manquer cruellement d'amour
ces dernières années selon les premières
estimations le remplacement du toit
pourrait coûter de 200 à 250 millions de
dollars
vous êtes d'accord pour dépenser 250
c'est incontournable développement de
l'est de montréal heure redynamiser
données du off ça passe absolument par
le remplacement de ses toiles québec et
la haye rio veut le stade ouvert à
l'année et savent que cette fois ci
l'erreur ne sera pas permise
les deux premiers toi n'ont pas
fonctionné celui là doit fonctionner
donc on est vraiment focus qualité le
concept choisi pour le nouveau toit
devrait être connu à l'été 2020 et on
sera là ni suivante qui le construira
ici jean-sébastien cloutier radio canada
montréal